yeah you look at pivetta's record
innings pitch a lot of walks gives up a
lot of home runs he has an outstanding
curveball he throws it a lot anthony
rizzo is three for nine in his career
against pavetto with a home run small
sample there are 10 umps in the hall and
it's almost certain that joe west who
has had more than his share of
controversies but you can't deny the
dedication of the craft the number of
games umpired well over 5 000 more than
anybody in the history of the game
he's going to be in cooperstown no
question
and i can't wait to hear his speech
probably play his guitar too
yeah cowboy joey
pop to the left side
and that finishes the yankees nestor
cortez getting set to go to work here
are his numbers
20
games 12 starts and he's really been a
breath of fresh air here's devers
lancelin of the white sox is pitching
today against cleveland he's also worthy
of cy young consideration
this ball is
lofted to right field and it's a chance
for judge and both teams go out in order
in the first at fenway park joey gallow
to the plate
and this time he's caught looking
breaking ball that did get the inside
corner now gleber torres with stanton at
first and one out
torres strikes out two down for gary
sanchez who didn't play last night
hitting 211 with 23 homers 54 rbis again
he's had some critical defensive laps
and now he's got him no question about
that one xander bogarts will start it in
the bottom of the second against nestor
cortez
and bogart strikes out first k put in
the book by cortez jd martinez jd at 287
with 27 homers and among the league
leaders with 40 doubles
two straight strikeouts to start the
second for cortez getting boguards and
martinez rude nedodor
steps in to start the top of the third
for the yankees if we're only
determining home field then head to head
takes care of it but if we're talking
about elimination they have to play a
game
or if we're talking about the difference
between being a division winner
and a wild card odor lists one to deep
right renfro shading his eyes back near
the wall where is it
it's in his glove
you know you take a look at him just
catching the ball it's a nice play but
if you track it off odor's bat
that was a very difficult catch
bobby dalbeck debuted last year
in the shortened season
called strike three
third strikeout for nestor cortez and
with one away it will bring up kevin
[ __ ] one-o is drilled the other way
high and deep to left field it is way
back and it is gone
kevin plawecki yanks one over the
monster and the red sox lead it one to
nothing
third homer of the year for plucky and
he picked a good time for it
absolute bomb
breaks the scoreless tie 408 off the bat
stand to base hit
in the second inning as he rocketed one
down the right field line
and that is their only base runner so
far against nick pavetta
stanton strikes out
quick and nifty work by pavetta
shift on against devers a whole lot of
territory between urchela and third base
and devers strikes out
see nestor gave him the little hesitated
leg kick there a little louis tian so
that has been very effective as we move
to the top of the fifth
he struck joey gallo out of the second
what's better than that
terrific seat
get a souvenir wow
beautiful day at fenway park his red sox
against the yanks
gallow couldn't check and for the second
time today he strikes out
five strikeouts now for pavetta as he
faces glebert torres
[Applause]
at the knees the dugouts call that and
boy was that a great pitch
gary sanchez has obvious liabilities
behind the plate and sometimes it can be
frustrating to watch him you think he's
making some progress
as a defensive catcher and then he
regresses again but at the plate he's a
fearsome hitter now here's bobby dolby
dalbeck sends one to deep right field
back goes judge back near the bullpen
and reaches to make a fine catch
schwarber had rounded second and
they almost got him
but he slides back into first safely
wow
i mean he caught that so casually
he has popped out and lined up
it gets by sanchez and here comes
schwarber to score the game's second run
with the other runners moving up
a 2-2
struck him out
in a big spot where he needed it and
froze one for two and a single in the
fourth
well
the wild pitch was a blemish but king
came in and did a nice job hansel robles
has faced aaron judge four times judges
o for four with three strikeouts
and he uncourts a wild pitch
a rum scores
as urchala comes across and gardner
scoots to third
and here as a chopper to deborah's he'll
come to the plate and he cuts gardner
down
here is sanchez
he too struck out twice against pavetta
and the o2 pitch got him
well it didn't look good for houck at
the start but
gets the double play ball and then the
strikeout stanton had a sharp single
then struck out and walked
after two out the yankees have loaded
the bases and stanton sends a long drive
to deep left center field it's a grand
slam home run
it's his 33rd of the season
he has seldom this animated kitty yeah
but everybody in that yankee dugout is
fired up here's dalbeck who's struck out
looking at a two-run homer taken away by
aaron judge what a huge play that was
judge reached into the bullpen to grab
it didn't leave his feet but he reached
with a backhand stab and of course he is
six eight so
definitely was gone but he brought it
back then bobby struck out
balbic with a high drive to deep left
center field gallow is there gardner
looking up and they're both spectators
[Applause]
dolbeck's 24th home run of the season
a happy red sox fan in the monster seats
and it's 5-3
so now [ __ ] hernandez represents both
the tying run at the plate and the red
sox last hope you can take a huge lead
with rizzo way off the line there he
goes
hit to her shell is left he feels it
throws across the diamond and that's
that